"Est-ce que ce sont des aliens
qui viennent enfin nous chercher ?"
Nous, on avait un vidéoclub qui était
à une demi-heure de chez nous.
Oh la vache !
Bonjour,
je m'appelle Léna Mahfouf,
mais tout le monde m'appelle
Léna Situations sur Internet
et j'ai 24 ans.
Mon premier pseudo,
c'était "Ma Foufoune".
Ce n'est évidemment
pas moi qui l'ai choisi.
C'était mon petit surnom au collège,
quand tout le monde a découvert
que mon nom de famille,
c'était Mahfouf.
Et ouai.
Je ne sais pas.
Je sais que j'ai plus de 2 millions
d'abonnés sur YouTube,
mais je ne sais pas exactement combien.
Attends, je vais regarder.
2 millions...
Vous savez ?
Moi, je ne sais pas.
Je devrais savoir cette info.
2 221 000.
Je n'avais pas vu que
j'avais passé les 200.
Merci !
Je voulais être créatrice de mode,
comme ma maman.
Quand j'ai découvert que tu pouvais
raconter des histoires
avec le milieu de la mode,
j'ai dit : "C'est ça, ce que je veux faire."
Complètement !
Là, je suis en plein dedans.
Tu veux toujours faire mieux
que ta dernière vidéo.
Tu veux que ta prochaine vidéo
soit mieux que la dernière,
et après tu rentres dans
une sorte de truc où...
tu te crames en fait.
Et tu perds un peu ce plaisir.
Les créateurs de contenu,
il y a toujours cette sorte de chose
où on est comparés
les uns avec les autres
et on nous fait croire qu'il y a de la
place que pour une seule personne.
Je pense que quand tu rentres là-dedans,
ça te bousille créativement et tu te dis :
"Mais lui, il a fait ça.
Lui, il avait une telle prod.
Lui, il a réussi à faire
une vidéo avec 5 cadreurs, etc."
C'est des choses bêtes,
mais qui peuvent te cramer.
Il faut vraiment réussir
à prendre du recul et à se dire :
"OK, je vais le faire pour moi maintenant."
Il y a un truc qui m'a beaucoup aidée,
on est plein de créateurs de contenu
et on fait tous le même métier
mais de façon très différente.
On se retrouve un peu
tous les uns, les autres.
Tu peux parler avec un Seb
que je connais bien,
qui m'a donnée beaucoup de conseils.
Mais tu as aussi des Squeezie,
des Mcfly et Carlito,
mais aussi des YouTubeurs
qui sont spécialisés
dans des chaînes hyper niches.
Au final, on a tous plein de sentiments
qui sont hyper communs.
C'est assez rassurant de se dire,
par exemple,
que cette panne créative ou ce burnout
ou cette hyper inspiration
ou ce méga plaisir,
il y a des gens qui sont
en train de vivre de leur côté
et quand on se retrouve tous ensemble,
c'est assez agréable.
Donc, je pense que le vrai
conseil qu'on m'a donné,
c'était juste de ne pas rester
seule enfermée là-dedans
et d'en parler avec les autres.
Avec les collègues de temps en temps,
c'est bien.
Je ne sais pas.
Moi, ça ne fait pas longtemps que je suis là.
Il faudrait demander aux autres.
Mais par exemple,
je prends Seb comme exemple
parce que ça fait 10 ans
qu'il est sur Internet
et que des gens ont grandi
avec Seb la Frite.
il a tous types de
contenus et qu'un coup,
tu peux avoir des challenges
vraiment de zozo
et puis tu peux avoir aussi
un docu sur la Papouasie,
après tu peux avoir des clips.
Des fois, je le vois,
il écrit des vidéos pendant 3 semaines.
Donc en gros, lui,
il se fait vraiment kiffer sur son contenu
et il ne parle que de choses qui l'excitent.
Donc, les choses qui l'excitaient
quand il avait 14 ans
ne sont pas les mêmes
que celles d'aujourd'hui
et ce n'est pas pour autant qu'il est resté bloqué dans ce qu'il faisait quand il avait 14 ans.
Je pense sincèrement que le modèle
'Seb the Fries' est pas mal.
Évidemment très honorée.
C'est un festival très prestigieux.
C'est quelque chose
qui est hyper important
parce que nous tous
qui faisons de la vidéo
et même si les plateformes
sont différentes
et la façon de créer est
complètement différente,
à la fin de la journée,
on a tous cette même envie,
c'est de raconter des histoires
ou au moins de divertir les gens
pendant un instant de leur journée.
Je trouve ça très inspirant et
ça me donne envie de voir aussi comment
eux réfléchissent quand ils créent un film.
C'est fascinant de voir le nombre
de personnes qui travaillent dessus.
Je suis aussi quand même très
au courant que la présence
d'influenceurs sur le Festival de Cannes
peut être ouvert à débat.
Je l'entends et je le comprends tout à fait,
mais je pense que c'est cool
de montrer aux jeunes
qui consomment des
contenus beaucoup plus courts
et beaucoup plus dynamiques
que le cinéma reste quelque chose d'extrêmement précieux.
C'est super cool et il faut
que l'on continue d'aller au cinéma.
Je pense que c'est le même souvenir
que tous les enfants des années 2000,
c'était le vidéoclub.
Nous, on avait un vidéoclub qui était
à une demi-heure de chez nous.
On y allait en vélo avec mon père.
C'était une demi-heure de vélo,
c'était une négociation avec mon père.
C'était une deadline pour regarder le film.
Ça se méritait,
ce n'est pas juste tu ouvrais Internet
et tu choisissais :
"Qu'est-ce que je vais regarder ce soir ?"
C'est plus compliqué que ça.
Le film qui m'a le plus marquée ?
Je suis une très grande fan de Wes Anderson.
Je pense que c'est la première fois
que j'ai vu un film où la photo te choque
au point où tu oublies l'histoire.
C'est tellement beau,
symétrique, réfléchi,
c'est très intelligent.
Tout le milieu du cinéma m'inspire de ouf
et me fascine parce que c'est
des années de travail.
C'est des milliers de personnes
qui se retrouvent sur un projet commun.
Tout ça pour 1h30 de film.
Nous, on le voit,
mais sur une échelle tellement plus petite,
puisqu'une qu'une vidéo
de 20 minutes déjà sur YouTube,
c'est une grande vidéo.
Tu te dis : "Le travail que c'est,
la patience des gens."
Moi, je trouve ça fascinant.
Je ne peux pas attendre un an de montage.
Je suis en mode : "Je l'ai,
il faut que ça sorte maintenant."
La patience du cinéma français me fascine.
Après, en termes de cinéaste, Wes Anderson !
Déjà, je vais vous dire un truc, à Cannes,
une journée équivaut à 10 jours à Paris.
C'est une ville où il se passe tellement
de choses que ton énergie est aspirée
par l'énergie du Festival de Cannes.
Le plus ouf,
c'est peut-être la soirée Elvis
qui était complètement folle.
Tu arrives sur une plage et puis d'un coup,
tu vois des petites étoiles dans le ciel,
tu te dis :
"Est-ce que ce sont des aliens
qui viennent enfin nous chercher ?"
Non, ce sont des drones qui sont
en train de former la silhouette
d'Elvis en train de danser.
Voilà, cette phrase n'existe pas dans un autre contexte que le Festival de Cannes.
Je comprends, j'entends.
Je pense que le but du Festival de Cannes
et d'inviter des influenceurs,
ça va être de mettre
en lumière justement tout le travail
que c'est et faire en sorte
que le cinéma garde cette énergie qu'il a.
Mais je pense que c'est une bonne façon
de montrer qu'il y a certains créateurs
de contenu pour qui ce n'est pas
simplement poster une photo et c'est bon,
ça s'arrête là.
Je vous promets,
j'ai fait des tournages
avec des youtubeurs où tu te dis
que c'est des prod vraiment de...
C'était des courts métrages,
c'était du film,
c'était de la prod de télé.
Donc, je pense que c'est
une bonne façon de mettre
de la lumière sur le travail
des créateurs de contenu,
ceux qui sont là pour parler de cinéma.
Également de mettre de la lumière
sur le cinéma parce qu'on a une audience
qui est peut-être moins familière avec ça
puisqu'on a moins grandi avec le cinéma,
parce que ce n'est pas la seule façon
qu'on a de voir un film.
La vache !
S'il y a un biopic sur moi, déjà... Merde !
Franchement,
si ce n'est pas Rihanna,
je ne sais pas si j'accepte.
S'il y a un biopic sur moi,
je pense que vous pouvez utiliser
toutes les images de mes vlogs
puisque j'ai déjà tout filmé,
donc je ne sais pas
ce qu'il y a encore à montrer.
J'ai déjà tout montré, donc vous pouvez
juste utiliser des images d'archives.
C'est un mélange de reconnaissance,
d'honneur et de gueule de bois.
Merci Brut de m'avoir appelée
pour venir papoter avec vous.
C'était un plaisir et j'espère
qu'on vous a divertis.
Des bisouilles et allez voir
l'interview avec Baz Lurhmann,
s'il vous plaît.